[Applause]
thank you for being here thank you thank
you fantastic thank you oh thanks yeah
um
i enjoy your christmas decorations
[Laughter]
what do you mean you mean
you're saying that almost as if you
don't really i think they're quite
pretty this year they are quite pretty
in there these look like polyps like
intestinal polyps here that have grown
that are colorful and pretty and
celebrating christmas but uh yeah i like
them yeah no i like them too i don't
decorate much for the holidays uh so i
i'm in tune with your decorations uh
okay i'm taking that as a terrible slam
what do you mean what do you mean you
don't decorate why don't you decorate um
i just feel like you know i don't have a
lot of ornaments like i haven't uh i
don't have a family and and so like the
only thing i could ornament would be
like one of those short trees which i
feel like just screams i'm single right
you know actually they make them now
ones that actually do scream you're
single
they have two aaa batteries right what's
going on why there's no fella in your
life uh
there's uh no but i um i never like all
those years that i was single and living
alone when i was working in la and here
in new york i never decorated yeah you
sort of need another person when you
decorate on your own it gets kind of sad
yeah like i found i was shopping the
other day because i keep trying you know
and i was looking at these really cute
stockings and i was with a friend i was
like how about these three or what about
these three and she's like who are the
three for
oh that's awful i like your friend who
the others for you're tragically alone
i know what kind of friend is that i
don't know but then the thing i do have
is my stepmother got you know the
nativity scene because catholic and uh
from the vatican in rome which is like
it's a really beautiful
fancy
you know thing with all the but there's
something kind of oddly doll house-y you
know when you're like setting up a
nativity scene by yourself in your house
right and so i find myself
making the people do bad things
maybe we don't want to know exactly what
you're having them do
but it's hilarious like what's funnier
than the donkey in the cradle right
right
i hear people getting offended all over
america right now i know a sound i've
heard before by the way
uh no you know what we had a big
nativity scene obviously i'm catholic i
grew up uh outside boston and we had to
you know we went to church every
day every day yes
four times a day you were great at that
last mass this one's even better uh and
they had a giant a big pretty big size
nativity scene and every year some wise
guy would take the baby because all the
other statues are leaning and praying
and like looking down at the baby jesus
and being really reverent every year
some guy would take the baby jesus and
put like a dollar bill there so everyone
in nativity seems like oh pray to money
whatever and then the priest would get
really mad said all right give it back
and someone have to come and put it back
and
just wacky catholic stuff from when we
were children
i know well it's funny because well
anyway so that's
what happened some mood altering drug
just kicked in for you
it's so funny because anyway
because i could keep going about like
you know like you have the baby jesus
like crawling away to safety or like you
know there's see why i stopped
yet i'm gonna make you go on and on what
else would the baby jesus do
i'm curious i want nine scenarios right
now
so yeah so that's just my decorating
it's sad uh now you shoot the show in
los angeles and i'm curious uh the big
thing for la celebrities to do is i've
never done it myself because i'm not out
there but you go to a lakers game and
you hang out and you sit right on the
sidelines and that's kind of the big
thing to do out there isn't it yeah well
it's i mean everything in la feels like
a weird schmooze fest you know you can't
it's the grocery store that's the cool
thing to do like it's all anywhere you
go but i went to one of my first laker
games where i had some fancy persons
seats not on the floor but this row
right behind the floor but still like
the floor is the is all the fancy fancy
people and i came down i was a little
late and who turns from the floor seats
but uh steven spielberg and his lovely
wife kate capshaw and um
they smiled at me
i i thought
but then i'm not gonna be the person the
first time at the lakers game
who's like me hi hi spielberg's like
like a freak so i not only didn't smile
back but i kind of glowered at them
angrily like
shut up steven spielberg or something i
hope you didn't say shut up steven
spielberg no i didn't cause he could
push a button and make all of us go
away no but i sort of like i looked at
them and then after they turned back
around i looked around and i think they
were smiling i mean then later somebody
said you know they have kids who like
the show and so they actually did
recognize he was smiling at me and now
you know they just walk around thinking
that's that mean mom from tv and like
i'm not putting her in schindler's list
two or whatever
[Music]
i don't think there's going to be a
schindler's list too
[Applause]
maybe
all right well gilmore girls which uh
everyone loves this show i mean it's a
great show
it's always on the list of like one of
the three best shows so uh good for you
airs tuesday nights at eight on the wb
that's true
also your name is lauren graham that's
true
and uh today is 12 20.
we'll be right back bill bailey that was
funny